- I have to say this because, yes,
we performed together and you are flawless
and it was incredible and I was like,
I usually don't get intimidated on a stage
and I was.
- whatever!
- I was, and here's the thing too, though.
I actually went to the Inaugural
Ball after, cause I sang.
- Really?
- Yes.
And you performed there,
- yes, I did.
and I didn't know you were gonna be there.
And first of all, I felt like such a like,
what am I doing here?
I'm in a ball gown
at something called an Inaugural Ball.
Like, I felt like pretty
woman in that store,
like I did not belong.
And like all this, I just,
it's like a very fancy event
and I just felt so fish out
of water and me and my husband
at the time were just kinda
like, yeah, we're just gonna
pretend like we're blending in,
like with all these, like,
you know, DC elite, like.
(laughs)
And all of a sudden you came
out and I was like, I love her.
I was like, wait, she's performing.
And then everyone was so
stiff in the room y'all
until Ledisi gets up
on stage and performs.
And Michelle Obama literally
like, no, she doesn't stand.
She rises.
Like, it's like, it's like,
like she rises.
And literally the entire room changed.
Like everybody went, oh, okay, cool.
And so everyone had such a great time.
You brought the best
vibe to that whole night.
It changed the whole night.
- But you do the same thing for me.
(audience applauding)
- No, I don't make people rise.
I make 'em clap.
It's fine.
- But it was so intense in the room.
So I had to change it up
- You did.
because I was like,
this should be a celebration,
not something dark.
This is exciting.
You know, let's lift the room.
- But it was interesting because she,
- I can't believe you remember all that.
Remembered it?
I was like, it was a moment!